Many people say yes to doing more than they have time to do.
Then when it is time to do what's promised, they discover they're too busy.
The trouble is almost everyone makes some faulty assumptions about the future.
According to researchers,...
...people over - commit because they expect to have more time in the future than in the present.
When tomorrow becomes today, yesterday's "yes" becomes today's "Oh no!"
Interestingly, researchers found people mistakenly expect a future surplus of time...
...more often than they expect a future surplus of money.
People just seem to be much more accurate in forecasting their need for money than time.
Because every day is a little different,...
...the nature of time fools us and we "forget" about how we use it.
Money, can be changed easily - such as four quarters for a dollar bill.
Our employment or family status and our supply of and demand for money...
...are relatively constant over time.
So compared with demands for one's time,...
...future money needs are relatively predictable from money needs today.
People often make commitments long in advance...
...that they would never make if the same commitments required immediate action.
Why? Because the future always looks ideal:
The fridge is stocked, the weather is clear, the train runs on schedule...
...and meetings end on time.
But today - all kinds of problems can and probably will happen...
...and our perfect schedule goes up in smoke.